the los angeles rams may have taken home
the trophy for winning the 2022 super
bowl but marvel fans were big winners
too getting two new trailers for a pair
of highly anticipated marvel cinematic
universe projects one was a 30 second tv
spot for the upcoming disney plus show
moon night giving viewers a much closer
look at the oscar isaac led superhero
project but that was just the appetizer
marvel studios served up an entire meal
with a new full length of doctor strange
in the multiverse of madness trailer the
doctor strange sequel is directed by sam
raimi whose work on the original
spider-man trilogy is largely why those
three films are still well regarded
among superhero movie fans benedict
cumberbatch is set to return as the
titular doctor strange and he is joined
by elizabeth olsen as wanda maximoff a
character who hasn't been seen in the
mcu since the end of one division the
finale of that disney plus series not
only cemented wonder's mcu
transformation into the scarlet witch
but also shows her starting to truly
explore the limits of her magical powers
since the multiverse of madness trailer
was released marvel fans have dissected
it frame by frame for clues and easter
eggs and some believe they found one
that may shed further light and wander's
true intentions when viewers finally
catch up with her again it looks like
the scarlet witch may still be crafting
her own intricate believable illusions
in the one division finale wonder flees
for a remote location where she begins
to study a powerful arcane book known as
the darkhold in hopes of learning how to
control and further hone her previously
unpredictable powers now fans are
getting a much clearer understanding of
the person wonder has become by the time
multiverse of madness picks up there are
two brief moments in particular in the
film's second trailer that fans have
picked up on the first features wonder
and doctor strange chatting as they
stroll through a lush green orchard
strange having just dealt with the
events of spider-man no way home asks
what do you know about the multiverse a
little later it seems the two characters
are in the same location but the scenery
has changed not only does wanda seem to
have swapped out her regular clothes for
her scarlet witch costume but she has
also shown facing strange in what
appears to be an ominous overwhelmingly
red environment the trailer may want
viewers to believe these two shots come
from different scenes in the movie but
mcu fans seem to think they're one and
the same a sleuthing fan long jumping
trainer 38 pointed out on reddit the
framing of these two scenes is nearly
identical with wonder scene over
steven's shoulder and vice versa also
steven strange appears to be wearing the
same outfit and scarf during both his
normal pleasant conversation with wonder
and his slightly more antagonistic
interaction with her in that strange
crimson environment in one shot the
trees in wonders orchard are also shown
to be in bloom in another they're barren
if marvel fans are correct the most
likely explanation for these two
seemingly different environments is that
the lush green setting we initially see
wonder and strange walking through is an
elaborate illusion wonder has whipped up
to mask her surroundings in response to
long jumping trainer 38's observation
and theory about the two moments peter
parker 72 remarked very nice catch can't
wait to see how this plays out at this
point in the mcu's timeline creating an
illusion like the ones fans are
theorizing about would be child's play
for wonder after all she successfully
hexed an entire town in one division i
made mistakes
and people were hurt understandably the
possibilities presented by this theory
have also led fans to begin speculating
about the greater implications of
wanda's reality warping powers in
multiverse of madness redditor rich
archon visitor 70 for one wrote i have a
feeling she'll be the villain at first i
think it's a faint for a bigger bad in
the second act though redditer
bromogodman commented the mcu deserves
its fair share of fallen heroes and
raging psychopaths if wonder manages to
be both i'm all in now all fans have to
do is wait to find out all the
implications of wonder and strange's
mysterious conversation in multiverse of
madness which releases on may 6th 2022
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the marvel cinematic universe are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one